IA Elda who's joining us from Tel Aviv
he's a political analyst and columnist
at haret newspaper very good to have you
with us on aler so Netanyahu has
rejected the Hamas plan calling it
delusional is his dismissal of this
proposal an official Israeli
dismissal I think that Natan is trying
uh to eat the cake and have it uh he uh
doesn't want to be portrayed as uh
someone who actually as you reported
mentioned before who has executed 100
Israelis whom his government has
actually abandoned some people would
even say betray four months ago so um he
doesn't actually leave the door open
when he completely refuses to put a
deadline to this War uh but on the other
hand I think that uh he doesn't want to
say no to uh the president of the United
States who is personally involved in the
the efforts to release the prisoners and
fin I want to remind you that there are
several American citizens among them um
he doesn't want to say no to Egypt and
to C right um so is Israel going to send
so is Israel going to send a ation to
Cairo for for this new round of
negotiations
then absolutely netan is interested in
the
negotiations but I'm not sure if as was
mentioned before uh that the majority of
the captives will be alive to wait and
they they cannot wait
until uh you know netan and Hamas will
find the absolute the ultimate Common
Ground the Gap is so wide the captives
are the last if not the only card it's
hard to say but they are the only card
that sinir is keeping right and he will
not let it go right before he knows that
uh the uh Palestinian who are uh for the
second time
refugees uh and he himself and the
leadership can get out of this alive so
let me ask you yeah yeah I wanted to ask
you a bit more about Netanyahu and and
the reasons behind his dismissal I mean
you say Netanyahu still wants to
negotiate the Americans and kataris have
said they believe that there are
elements in this proposal that are
workable the kares have said that it's
positive what issues precisely is
Netanyahu um and Israeli I I guess
concerned about what issues are they
concerned about when it comes to this
proposal is it the duration of the
ceasefire the notion of ceasefire itself
what are the main concerns for the
Israelis
here the main concerns is uh how and
whether netan can really meet his
commitment to get rid of Hamas and uh
this is the minimum that he needs in uh
the political Dimension uh in order to
survive politically he has to make sure
to his
constituency that uh there is not going
to be another October 7th which
according to him and maybe he climed a
very high too high tree and uh there is
no lettera to get out of there that
Hamas can afford to give him okay um the
only way now right now is if uh Qatar
maybe Egypt will convince the leaders of
Hamas to get out of Gaza to have a safe
passage to a third country and uh to
allow some kind of a new government that
will be led by the Palestinian Authority
with some kind of participation of Hamas
in in this in the day after the war okay
AKA elar thank you so much for sharing
uh your thoughts with us AA Elder is
from uh the haret newspaper columnist
joining us from Tel Aviv thank you for
your time